[Music]
committing to your characters tonight
always how much practice and preparation
did it take for the two you live like
anime characters so she's seen me much
breakfast live in that mode okay so give
us the deets behind your characters so
you are tonight so we are Miyazaki movie
characters Princess Mononoke and I'm
Ashley taka yeah and we've these are
longtime favorite characters of ours so
we're back again well you look great and
I love how you're like no no no I can't
smell guys I bet it's rice raised by
Wolf's you know I'm gonna be that's why
you're sticking to the butterfly
butterfly keep hitting everyone with my
antennas sorry guys
that proboscis man it just gets in the
way have you guys been to Heidi's party
before and it's always a great event did
she show up already did we miss her
we are waiting patiently to see what
she's dressed as this year right no
we'll catch up on the Instagram before
you get inside thank you hopefully your
grand entrance will be really soon
[Music]